i'm coming for you and sings la la la
really creepily
i'll watch out for that one
[Music]
all right so on the show we have a
segment called hashtag because toddlers
where parents share their wildest
toddler stories but since it's almost
halloween we're doing a special version
of our favorite hashtag by having
parents tell us
the creepiest things your toddlers have
done last time i did this i got super
freaked out and worried about
many people's parenting skills
then she said no it'll be soon
screw this here goes nothing okay
[Music]
when my daughter was little she would
talk about her other family that she had
before
oh my god is that
real oh she said they all turned yellow
and died
and now i'm her mommy run
get out of your house now i hope my
daughter
never tells me anything that creepy i
will never sleep in my house again
[Music]
when my son was about two we moved into
a brand new house he suddenly had an
imaginary friend
i asked what the friend's name was and
he said john brinkson oh he's a full
name
that was freaky enough but then oh but
when i asked where he lived he just
pointed at the ceiling
oh no no no no
i don't do ghosts either i'm like i've
literally talked to like somebody said
there's a ghost mouse and i was like
cool if you're here i'm here we can
co-exist like don't bother me
like i don't want to be bothered
my daughter now 26 was five or six and
my grand passed away and we went to the
funeral she turned to me and said
mommy don't be sad granny is okay she is
sitting on the cough and telling me
to tell you not to be sad that's not
creepy that's what if that was real
you know i'm just saying
[Music]
i was trying to take a nap and my
daughter had this imaginary friend
i hear her telling her friend that she
needs to be quiet because
mommy and [ __ ] are sleeping a few
seconds later she's like no i don't want
my mommy to go away
oh my god
oh my god and
i'm done nope
my second daughter just likes to walk
around with a raggedy and doll and
repeat
oh my gosh
she walks around with a raggedy and doll
and repeats i'm coming for you
and sings la la la really creepily
i watch out for that one like sleep with
one eye open
tell her she's not in the will like
[Music]
i'm telling you kids see some crazy my
daughter was about three years old when
she told me
there was an old man standing in her
bedroom with a suitcase
i simply asked her if he was a nice man
or a mean man
to not freak her or myself out
lol she answered he's a nice man i think
he's waiting for someone
i'm out well i always want to hear about
the wild things your kids are doing
so find me on twitter facebook and
instagram and use the hashtag because
toddlers
to tell me your creepy little stories um
and
maybe i'll read yours next time and then
have nightmares about them
fine man in a suitcase nope
[Music]
you